the
so
oh my god hi strani thank you for the read hello all the all the leaflings hi
um i think you were having a were you having a members only stream i think
that might have been it what you guys do alabama raid what do you mean alabama raid
huh
hi
why did i say my mic is off use microphone
strani played roller coaster tycoon oh i heard of that game it's like an old one right
it's an it's an old old day game thank you for becoming a member geese louise
they're raiding alabama what
commanded to kiss you oh okay get over here get over here give me a kiss
i'm ready give me a kiss get over here and give me a kiss i'm sorry if my voice sounds kind of
cracky i just woke up from a nap i just woke up from like a really long nap i slept until like
like oh my god i don't know
i slept until like like two to five i think or two to five thirty
it was not a great nap i woke up like really really um i woke up really like
hot thank you for the super chat strani to kiss your sister at the end of stream
ah okay yeah i woke up really sweaty and i woke up like
uh with a headache and i still have that headache right now so yeah
the weather is really hot here yeah
how's your weather how's the weather up there
here it's really hot it's really really hot
somewhere we'll do that to you yeah you could though no that's why i'm using the fan it's um
like i don't know is it hotter today than usual
that looks like my fart face i just went to get my phone
um it feels hotter today than usual
yeah it's 28 degrees right now
oh it's gonna rain soon oh no it's not gonna rain i really like it when it rains at night
it's really it's really cozy don't call it your fart face why it's my fart face though
it's literally my fart face like that's my fart face how it was like it was like
it's not doing the
uh
well then i have a little more
sorry about that
it sounded wet i think my underwear is dry don't worry or at least it's not wet from poop
it's not wet from poop so it's okay
nothing can shit there's some strong muscles down there it's it gets loud down there because
it's very tight it's very tight so i have to push really hard to get it out that's why it's so loud
do that while sitting on a cake
uh maybe maybe if you donate if you pay for the cake else because i want to ruin a perfectly
good cake you know i want to eat the cake but i can't eat the cake if i fart on it so
if you pay for the cake i'll i'll uh if you pay for the cake i'll i'll fart on it for you
let me um oh shit it says i have to update puppy play time oh wait in the mind huh let me open the
game i'll bake the cake myself that's even nicer excuse me i feel like i have to turn up my ring
light my tracking is kind of bad i turned it down because i had a headache but i should probably
bring it back up because my glass is always getting the way of my tracking i think oh that's
loud sorry that's the game have you met my friend huge ass yeah your friend is actually connected to
me okay i'm sitting on your friend right now i'm sitting on huge ass okay um
oh let's see
change this thank you for the twenty dollar uh super chat for the cake fund
um how do i change the resolution here uh night 12
this can you what um 720 back yes here we go
should we talk more
we can talk more oh my background music is off i've yet to catch an emmy stream is this a typical
yeah it is what was that drone what drone are you don't suffocate huge ass huge ass is still needed
oh shit i can't i can't read that hold on let me go let me go open stream elements
oh i'll i'll i'll step away from your face for a second stream elements
um
strani watched your four hundred dollar clip she thinks you have bigger boobs than he does
who is he do you mean she does bigger boobs than she does i think i might have bigger boobs than
strani yeah that's possible
um
stay close get back in my face okay i'll get back in your face then i feel like you can
you can see everything up here you can see everything up close you can see how
i my ear disconnects so i i changed my rigging um for my hair i wanted it to be more flowy
because before it wasn't this flowy right so i changed it i changed the physics for my hair
to be more flowy but the problem is because i did that um when i turn too hard you can see
or even when i just turn you can see that my um my ear disconnects from my face
that's my own fault and then um i'm doing more it's almost done it might even be done before
the live 2d rigging stream i'm doing a little more and um that that that what i'm doing will
probably also add some more silly silly awkward um mistakes but that's okay it'll look cute it's okay
she cut her ear off her arms were cut off her legs were cut off her ears were cut off
her tongue was cut off and then they cooked her limbs in a pot and ate it i should actually keep
that tab open i deleted it uh me
imivian girl
no it's not not good stuff it's not not good stuff it's um it's a it's a what's it called
how do i turn this off
thank you for the super chat big head it's not big it's just it just looks big because of
the camera okay there's a meme
because i like to watch true crime shows i like to watch true crime shows so um
this meme uh relates to me a lot i think this is the original
oh it's a fucking ad
oh i muted youtube no i didn't mute youtube what
oh there we go here i'll show you show it to you
what the fuck
how do i
how far does it open
there we go this is the meme
i hope it's loud enough her arms were cut off her legs were cut off her ears were cut off
her tongue was cut off her nose was cut off her eyeballs were blocked out
that would probably be your reaction to the true crime stuff i watch
another meme you're talking about i love it as someone who used to sleep to true crime in horror
stories yeah like that's what it's like sometimes hot girl activity it kind of is all hot girls watch
really messed up true crime stuff
i am drinking coffee but i already finished like half the cup
want to get emi like that
you want to turn me into a nugget but it says her tongue was cut off like nuggets of tongue still
how are we supposed to kiss if i have no tongue
any chance you're a fan of my favorite murder no i haven't watched that one
i watch like um like stephanie sue i watch i gotta open my
i don't know i watched like the basic white girl ones because i'm a basic white girl so that's
that's the one and all that running that spongebob someone sent me this spongebob clip on marshmallow
and for some reason every time i open my sponge not my spongebob oh my god
every time i open my youtube tab it automatically like saved that freaking link and goes to that link
and automatically plays it i watch like kendall ray daniel kirstie stephanie sue
um rotten mangle which is the same girl uh elinor neal like i watched the basic white girl ones
you just receive no give
it's okay well that's kind of hot but i still want to give
it's a little hot but i still want to give
you watch stephanie sue yeah i do
magnetic tongue attachment that's not possible no arms means no handles no legs means no footsies
yeah and my feet are cute you you said it yourself that my feet are cute
wait my freaking my forehead hurts because of my headache i i'm kind of happy today because i
i don't know how to explain why i'm happy i'm happy today because i found out something that
i was worried about and i found out that it's not true and um it makes me happy
because i was really worried about something but it's it's in the end it worked out so that
makes me happy i can't tell you full details but i was really i was i was worried about something
but it turns out i didn't have to worry about it so that's nice and i like that and that's why
i'm happy today i can't tell you
how about this maybe one day in like six months you'll learn what i was happy about there
weird al isn't real he can't hurt you and me i found out real al isn't actually real
i'm gonna wipe my glasses off real quick they feel really dirty
i feel like neuro someone would call you a ginger
what why why
huh i used to wear contact lenses when i was a flush tuber because the freaking glare from my um
me the freaking glare from my um my glasses on my ring like it used to be so bad that like
i couldn't even stream with my glasses on so i used to wear contact lenses i used to wear
like uh blue ones and gray ones those were my favorite colors because they the blue ones were
a nice contract contrast because i had pink hair and the gray ones just looked cool
as long as everything is okay and you're happy that's all we care about i am i am i am
let me forget about in six months well that's okay you might not even be here in six months
so that's okay like had a chromium no no no i just wear like like two contact lenses of the same color
i hate contacts it feels weird touching my eyes and
usually you're not supposed to feel them like at all you're not supposed to feel them at all
so you shouldn't be feeling your contact lenses like touching your eyes
how did you put them on versus remove them i thought about giving them a try but knowing
my clumsy self i don't want my eyeballs messed up your eyeballs your eyeballs are actually a
lot more sturdy than you think they are like they're not just gonna fall out you're not just
gonna scratch them that easily like your your your eyebrows can handle a rubbing okay you can
your eye your eyeballs can handle a little bit of um you know a little bit of touching a little bit of
messing around so it's okay don't be scared it doesn't hurt thank you for the 199 super chat
i'll always be here for my little sister oh i'll always be here for my big brother
you and your genma should play crab game maybe i don't know i'm never someone that like
i don't i'm not a huge collab person like if my genmys want to collab with me i'll do it but like
i don't think about like collabing with a lot of people which is surprising because i've
collabed with a few people already but like in the past i never collabed with like anyone
because when i watch a streamer i usually like to just only watch that streamer
but that's just me i don't know do you guys like watching collabs i usually just
oh my god i just found out that my gamer subs package is on the way i check my email yippee
i opened my phone to check something but then i forgot what i was gonna check
collabs are good for networking they are
um like i don't mind video collabs i think those are fun um but i'm just never someone that like
thinks about collabing with a bunch of people i don't have the strawney mindset i need to change
that i need to change that i need to get that that strawney mindset
collabs good but collabs all the time get tiring that's true too
oh yeah i want i remember what i wanted to check
oh my god we're only fucking
shit i can't do math let me let me let me get out the calculator
we're only 28 28 subscribers away from 17k wow that's only that's only um
that's only 3000 away from 20k wow thank you
it took me and i'm very singly long to calculate that
yeah strawney consumes the other person after the collab absorbs their asmr skills too
oh shit i shouldn't do a collab with strawney then huh
well if it's with people my little sis likes to interact with well
i'm going to collab with someone i like to interact with of course of course
what do you mean i'm not gonna collab with someone i don't like
what are you afraid that we would like the other two more and that's a lot of you no no
no someone fucking i burp so much someone said i had good i literally i don't actually burp
that much when i'm alone i don't know what's wrong maybe it's because i'm drinking a lot on stream
because i do drink a lot more on stream than i do like um when i do like normally so maybe
the the amount of drinking is causing me to burp i don't know i i don't burp this much in real
life truly i don't or maybe it's the talking or maybe it's the nervous burps too i don't know
i really don't i think it might be the talking too i remember when i'm i remember when i call
people i do burp a lot like a couple days ago was it a couple days ago or was it literally
yesterday i think it was literally yesterday i called lulu lasso maybe we can do a collab with
lulu lasso i called lulu lasso a couple days ago and we talked and i was burping a lot in her ear
you saw a lot of air that's probably it yeah
yeah the talking plus the drinking
kai foo and denpa were really nice collabs um
i really gotta finish my script with denpa i've been so so slow with it i worked a little bit
on it today but i've been so slow with it she's been so patient if i was here i'd be like send
me that fucking script bitch you're taking too long did you drink a lot are you the one who started
peeler no that was who started peeler i don't know what was the first to piss on on youtube oh not
on youtube who was the first to piss on twitch fuck not twitch what the fuck is wrong with me
twitter what was the first to piss on twitter someone keeps asking english or spanish what does
that mean you think i speak spanish english was it i see the first to piss on twitter
was it okay then it was i see that started peeler and the rest followed
the first upload was actually sheebie huh it was you were i see oh whoa whoa whoa don't get
twisted i was not the first to piss on twitter no no no no no no no no no no no i see then you then
she be none of you guys are getting the timelines all wrong you guys are getting the timelines all
mixed up it was either i see or she be that posted first and then you know the next one followed
and then i followed and then no one else has done it me first get out of here with your faking gay news
also i want to clarify i never use gay as an insult okay i i'm not trying to insult you guys
it's just a silly it's just a silly tease it's just a silly silly silly i'm being silly don't worry
you were fitler i see as peeler
it's the meme english or spinach depending on the answer you get the english or spanish version
of the first one to move is gay ah i've never heard of that it means is the first one i enjoyed
well it's the last one you get enjoyed too because i'm not fucking doing it again
canceled oh canceled me i'm surprised i mean honestly i guess i have it coming i guess i have
it coming don't die it's not even my fault she had it coming or wait no how does the song go
he had it coming he had it coming he only has himself to blame if you'd have been there
if you'd have seen it uh i i bet you you would have done the same
okay why are you acting so gay anonymous tip six dollars and ninety cents can you please
clarify do you like it when your big brothers are gay or not
okay i'll clarify you heard it here first
obviously i want my big brother to be interested in me and it's pretty straight to like a girl
if you're a guy so i don't want my big brother to be a shipper saying gay okay but
if you want to kiss another big brother in front of me i won't be opposed to it
okay okay there you heard it here first
meeting adjourned that's that's your answer
thank you for becoming a pin pal josh is it gay to like me no it's very straight to like a girl
so don't be don't i don't want my big brothers to be gay unless it's for each other
okay okay yeah big bro on big bro action
how do you do how about you do another endurance stream um um i could but i feel like
i should do something else i don't know i feel like i should be more creative i shouldn't
copy myself right i feel like i shouldn't copy myself and and do the same thing
no
why is it the super chat did i fuck something up why isn't the super chat stream elements
talking out loud thank you for the two dollars what about your possible big sisters yeah they
can kiss each other too they can kiss each other too if they want only if they want don't feel like
i'm like pressuring you into it um is it an alert
settings super chat alerts
alert duration text-to-speech settings
oh it has to be back some minimum five dollars okay that makes sense yeah yep that makes sense
uh okay
i did change yeah no it's not it was five dollars let me the the uh the requirement is five dollars
also fucking smoothie did a clip on me and it's already at 24 000 views in eight hours
which means 24 000 people have seen my boobs that's way more people than i expected
that's way more people than i expected when i showed my boobs
i got a few hate comments too of like people calling me like a whore which like yeah
this is veeler what do you expect that's that's the point of us that's why we're here
so
and then some people were disappointed too right sorry sorry
it's like the opposite with me and strawney her model has boobs and mine doesn't but in real life
it's the opposite
but i'm glad you guys like them yeah of course some people were disappointed of course
i'm false advertising over here i keep accidentally closing the tab i need to stay open okay um
um i think i'm gonna get more coffee or maybe i should fill it up with water
uh i should fill it up with water shouldn't i
okay wait i'm gonna ask you i'm gonna ask you right now
ask you right now oh my god shut up
uh start a poll what should i get coffee water
you better not choose water you better not choose water
lots of people were hoping you were flat it's very very hard to lots of people some people are
so strange and don't understand like like you think strawney asked for like fucking
pics when she hired us like what do you mean like you think that was part of her
hiring the character like when when she was hiring Azura do you think she she had the
requirement of being over 200 pounds like no of course not she's not asking us for body
pics to make sure we actually fit the characters why are you acting so gay
oh i have to read that uh i know this would be mean but i would love to know what the haters
say about vealer nature girls i love to laugh at all the guys wasting their time working about
vtubers i don't want to say it i don't want to say it it's really not that bad and it's really
not a lot fuck you you're seeing water uh okay fine i'll get water like you can probably you can
look yourself and see it's pretty easy to find it's pretty easy to find even on the smoothie clips
just go sort by newest and you'll find them yeah so uh are you as tall as a building
like no of course she did want to find like um she wanted to find like a black vtuber to fill
in Azura's role because that would be kind of awkward to like put a white girl as Azura but
like otherwise like otherwise you know she's not making sure we look like our freaking models
that's it's already hard enough to fill in a character you know it's hard enough to fill in
like someone that that you feel like fits in with what you're looking for and also has like
all the requirements that they were looking for too
congrats on 17k wait did we already reach it no way
no freaking way we reached it
ah
yippee we reached it that's so fun
yippee thank you mimosa hi i didn't see you hi thank you we made it to 17k oh that's exciting
i'm happy thank you for subscribing
okay i'll go get the water and then um
and then we can start the game
now the song is stuck in my head
subscribe if you like the video what's the name of the song
oh it's from um
i think it's from a musical it's from the musical um
chicago and it's called self-block tango okay i'll be rb i'm gonna go get uh uh
um
Hi, I'm back.
I wasn't actually pissed and I just used that as my BRB screen.
She's getting the water from the toilet.
She's reducing water to drink.
Oh my god, stop.
Okay, yeah, I didn't say much while I was talking.
Oh my god, it's already been 40 fucking minutes.
Oh my god, okay, I'm going to start the game.
I mean, is that good?
Is that a good size?
Let me see, game capture.
Yeah, it's good.
I think the audio is also good.
I'll turn off my background music.
Here we go.
She's becoming a real streamer.
I just feel like, yeah, I just feel like there's less
gameplay if I talk too much, you know?
Ah, fucking, okay.
Should I watch this if I miss the first thing?
Oh, you're not loud enough.
Yeah, you can watch.
You can watch whatever you want.
You don't have to follow along to any time.
You don't have to follow along to any time when.
Yeah.
There's a really cool room in there that powers literally
all of play care.
I can give you a key down there.
Thank you, Ollie.
Your strictly access.
Okay, we've been down here already.
I think we just first got down here when I started, right?
Remember we did tell you we love your rapping?
I guess that's true.
Thank you for liking my yapping.
When I was a kid, I was mostly quiet.
I never really yapped too much.
And then when I did yap, my mom would get annoyed.
Litter here.
Oh, litter stops here.
You can fix it.
What?
Re-recycle it.
Oh, that's cool.
Okay.
Can I see the character in the mirror here?
Or am I crazy?
I think I'm going crazy.
Ollie might be the goat?
The goat?
Like the goat is in like the greatest of all time?
That kind of goat?
Mom's not here yet, unless she is, which is weird.
Mom is not here.
I can yap as much as I want, now that mom is gone.
Yeah, I'm in debt.
Debt, debt.
I'm in debt for the yapping.
Is it just me, or do I see like, is it my monitor?
I see some glitches on my screen.
Do you see that?
Have you been seeing that?
Is that my monitor, or is that supposed to happen in game?
I do have really old monitors.
Bro, some people fucking hate the frilly stuff
I have on my monitors.
I think they're cute.
You don't see glitches?
Maybe I'll make a full screen.
I see some glitches on my screen.
Oh, come on.
Why does that do that?
Why does it do that?
Never mind, we're not going full screen.
Frills cause interference?
It's not the frills.
I see glitches on my screen, like TV glitches?
Like it goes up the screen, like that.
Do you see that?
Wait, holy shit.
Oh, you don't see it.
Wait.
Channan's compare on OBS.
OK, you don't see it.
It's just me.
OK, it must be my monitor.
I do have really old monitors.
When I was making my PC, no, we definitely don't see it.
OK, OK.
Tearing enable v-sync.
What the fuck is v-sync?
Have you tried turning it on and off again?
Tearing, v-sync.
Wait, what's v-sync?
What's v-sync?
What the fuck is v-sync?
Do you need to turn on v-sync?
Wait, what's v-sync?
A graphics option to fix tearing in settings.
Is it here?
Graphics?
A setting v-sync.
I mean, I mean, what?
What, I mean?
Yeah, I'm not a gamer.
I don't know.
No, this shows v-sync.
It's under display.
Oh.
So yes?
OK, I turned it on.
I have really old monitors, because when I, I think it's
fixed.
When I was buying my PC, I forgot that when you buy an
actual real computer, it only comes with a computer and
nothing else.
Like, it doesn't come with monitors.
It doesn't come with, like, what's it called?
What's it called?
No peripherals, peripherals.
Like, it doesn't come with speakers.
It doesn't come with speakers.
It doesn't come with monitors.
It just comes with the PC block, right?
And I completely forgot about that.
So when I finally saved up enough to buy a computer by
doing commissions, I forgot that it doesn't come with
peripherals.
So yeah, no keyboard, no mouse.
So I spent my entire, like, PC budget on the PC itself.
And then I was like, wait, I can't use it.
I can't use the PC.
I don't have anything to connect it to.
I forgot it's just a pewter, and it doesn't come
with the pewter parts.
What am I supposed to do here?
I feel like I'm going in a circle.
Help me.
Yeah, it's a very fancy and heavy paperweight now.
You got to open the door if you want to progress.
This door?
A very fancy, heavy paperweight.
And so I went on Kijiji, which is, like,
Emmy What, which is, like, the Canadian Craigslist.
And I looked up, what other door is there by the big machine?
There's no door.
What door?
Something I've been having!
Other side?
There's no door.
You just looked at it.
Find the cage and open the door on it.
Oh, this door.
This isn't a fucking door.
Oh, it is a door.
OK.
Enter the gas production.
You've got the key.
Now the question you're probably asking yourself is,
where does it go?
Well, head back out, and you should find a door just
to the left of the cable car you took down here.
So I went on Kijiji, and I found, it's not this door, is it?
This is just a door hanging against the...
Am I supposed to find another door?
Back of the stairs.
Oh, right.
I didn't pay attention to what he was saying.
I'll be honest.
I kind of blacked out.
He said something about going left.
You're so quiet, Hopi Hopscotch.
Oh, wait.
I'm being stupid.
I can just turn my own sound up.
There we go.
OK, there we go.
OK, whatever.
No.
What about you?
She sounds like Fluttershy.
Kind of.
Hi, I'm CraftyCorn.
Actually, it's more breathy.
Pass me the blue please.
Hi, you remember me.
OK.
That might be intentional.
I mean, yeah, that makes sense as to why it would be intentional.
When are we getting MLP fanfic reading?
I don't know.
Oh, one day.
I gotta finish my fucking story.
Yeah, I went on Kijiji, which is Canadian Craigslist,
and I found one monitor was free.
I had to stand outside this guy's house
because he told me what time to come.
Well, yeah, he told me what time to come at, right?
And so I get there at the right time.
He lives super far away from me.
I get there at the right time, and I knock on his door.
Why are you acting so gay?
I love how little sister didn't apologize for yelling.
Looks like we've got to bring back the shell color.
You weren't helping me.
It's fine for me to yell.
It's fine.
Where am I supposed to go?
Do you know who the voice actress is?
Is it Fluttershy's voice actress?
That'd be cool.
I don't think so.
It doesn't sound like Fluttershy that much.
There's a door with red light you're looking for that.
There's a door with red light.
I stand up.
I knock on his door when I get there and nobody answers, right?
And so he said that he'll have the monitor in his garage
and his garage door is open.
So I go into his garage and I look around and it's not there.
So then I just stand there like, what do I do now?
Because I wanted this monitor but he didn't show up to our meeting time.
So I just stand there for a little bit.
Looking around, snooping in his garage.
And finally I see a neighbor next door and I'm like,
hey, have you seen Blank's name?
I was supposed to meet up with him and then the neighbor's like,
oh yeah, Blank went to go pick up his kids from school and I'm like,
huh?
And he's like, but his wife should be in the house.
Like his wife should be home and I'm like, oh, okay.
So I go back.
You make it so easy to begin.
I needed that freaking monitor, man.
Free monitors sound super sketchy.
It was not sketchy.
This monitor is so old.
It's right next to the Playhouse to me.
Playhouse.
Which one is the Playhouse?
Hold on, there was a map, wasn't there?
There was a map.
Is this the map?
No.
And so I go knock on his door again and his wife doesn't answer me.
So I literally stand there for like 30 minutes.
And finally he gets home from picking up his kids, the billboard.
It was right in front of her.
The billboard is the map?
Oh, the billboard is the map.
Playhouse.
You said it was in front of the Playhouse?
Where am I?
Oh, this is the Playhouse.
Or next to the Playhouse you said it was?
The left of the stairs you took coming in.
Coming in?
Which stairs did I take coming in?
Oh, there's a red light over there.
Oh, wow, this thing keeps going.
Finally he gets home from bringing his kids back from school.
And I'm like, hey, remember me?
You were supposed to give me a free monitor that you put up on Kijiji.
And he's like, oh yeah, sure, I'll get it for you.
And then he goes into his frickin' house.
He goes into his house and brings back the monitor.
It wasn't even in his frickin' garage.
I snooped through his garage for nothing.
The dog day is so bad.
What does that mean?
That's the thing.
Why did the wife not answer the door?
Because she was home.
I saw her.
She was home.
And she didn't answer.
And it's not like I'm some fucking creepy stranger.
I'm just a girl.
I'm not going to, you know, I'm just a girl.
I'm not going to break into the house.
I'm just here for the monitor your husband put up on Kijiji.
Don't forget your mask.
Watch your step.
False?
She probably thought you were a solicitor.
The beating heart of the whole evil play care system.
All that gas you see coming from the machine is made right here in the factory.
It's called the red smoke.
Right now, it's all headed off to the right.
We need to make that red smoke go left instead.
That's how we can get to him.
The machine will probably have a few dumb safeguards for you to work around.
But I think you can do it.
Sorry, I'm fitting myself off with my shirt.
Ten hour puzzle.
You're a possible home wrecker.
I hope not.
That would be, that would be concerning for her husband.
Didn't you commit high treason?
What?
Me?
No.
Just take the shirt off.
Stop trying to get me to play games naked.
Um.
Okay, no power.
Okay, first steps first.
Get power.
Probably by putting power stuff in here.
Right?
Isn't it more fun that way?
No, not really.
Uh, no.
Do not enter.
Let me in.
Let me go in.
Let me enter.
You're in your own home.
It can't hurt to wear a bit less.
Um.
I don't know.
I like wearing clothes.
Like I even like, I don't know.
Do you guys wear underwear when you go to sleep?
I know some people do and some people don't.
I like to wear underwear in my sleep.
Oh, sleigh.
I just said sleigh.
That was kind of cringe.
Oh, chat is gone.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, some people don't.
Some people don't wear underwear in their sleep.
Like my mom doesn't wear underwear in her sleep.
But she always like, she's always like,
I don't wear underwear in your sleep.
Like when I was younger,
she didn't put underwear on me to go to sleep.
A free monitor.
You found it in an online listing far away from your house.
The guy's in there known as answering the door.
You said, you said it like this sounds sketchy as fuck.
It was in a nice neighborhood.
Okay.
It was in a cute safe neighborhood.
There was literally a school like right next door
with a bunch of kids playing over there.
Like I'm not going like fucking into the countryside
to get this monitor.
I'm not like driving two hours away just for a shitty monitor.
Why do you not?
I don't know.
I don't know why she doesn't.
Doesn't the fabric drive you insane?
No, it doesn't.
Extended wire links.
Swapping hands is easy.
Why is this such a shitty screen?
Air jets.
The countryside is safe?
Cities are the danger?
I don't know.
It was a nice family neighborhood.
I thought it was fine.
But I guess that's what they all think, right?
And then they get kidnapped and they get cut into pieces
and cannibalized and cooked and stuffed in the fridge
and buried in the backyard.
And they get their tongues cut off.
And their legs cut off.
And their arms cut off.
And their ears cut off.
And then they get flushed down the toilet.
Okay, that was something about the jet pack.
Oh, I got it!
Press two or scroll to swap hands.
Ooh!
Wait, but this isn't the jet pack.
What is this?
What does this one do?
Can we watch shitty analog horror one day?
Sure, if you want to.
No.
Purple head makes you jump.
How do I jump?
Oh, and falling.
No.
Why is there your hand here?
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, it didn't...
Do your best?
What do you mean do my best?
I'm always doing my best.
Purple hand pads.
Okay, yeah, I figured that out.
Am I doing good?
Am I getting further?
Jet pack deploys and explains where your legs don't snap.
Okay, okay.
Can I climb up these?
No.
You're doing very good.
Ah, she's such a gamer.
I wish I had a controller.
I feel like I'd be more comfortable playing with a controller,
but I only have Wii controllers.
I don't have Xbox controllers.
Should I get an Xbox controller?
Because Xbox controllers work with...
Why is there just a circle here?
Is it for stupid people like me and to confuse them?
It works with windows, right?
I don't know if it's true.
Is it true?
Ah!
Oh.
It's like...
I got a 230 inch ultra wide that I don't use,
but I learned the Caribbean.
I'll send you the ticket.
Chill.
I live in a nice neighborhood.
I don't need your monitors.
I have mine now.
I'm not really a fancy monitor person.
I don't really care about fancy monitors.
I got the ones that were the cheapest ones,
because like I said, I spent all of my budget on the PC itself.
So I use an Acer one.
What's the other one?
I covered it with stickers.
I don't actually know what brand it is.
Does that say...
I think it's Asus.
I think people are gonna shit on me for my pronunciation of Asus.
Is it Asus?
It's broke.
Read somewhere if a game has the label for Microsoft Windows.
It has the native support for Xbox controller.
Okay.
I'll try to get it exposed.
Wait.
Whoa.
Red water.
Why is it red?
I'll try to get it.
Oh, no.
I can't make that jump.
Ah, shit.
Ah, that was close.
Okay.
Is this a C-bussy monitor Asus?
A switch controller should work as well.
No way.
No way it does.
Does it actually?
I do have a switch one.
I feel like I'd be more comfortable leaning back.
I have to, like...
Where am I supposed to go from here?
I have to, like, crouch over like a shrimp.
A switch pro controller should absolutely work.
Oh, I don't know if mine is switch pro.
Well, let me look up what a switch pro controller looks like.
I don't actually know what a switch pro controller is.
Switch pro controller?
Oh, I think I have one of those.
Yeah, I have that.
A switch has less support for games, but it does.
I have a central column pulled down.
Do I need to jump to the platform that is there?
Central column.
There's a central column.
Put a nice Xbox Series X controller down.
Wait, so how do I get up here?
Do I have to parkour this shit?
It doesn't want to get pulled down.
Oh, it doesn't want to get pulled down.
Now what?
Now jump?
I'm not going to make it.
What do I run in this game?
It's shift, right?
There's a pipe to the left?
What, am I supposed to do something with it?
Dude, I'm not going to make that.
Jump on the pipe to the left.
Oh.
And then do I...
Oh, I'm not going to make that either.
I knew I wasn't going to make it.
Buy once, cry once.
Get an Xbox Elite controller into your set.
I don't know what that means.
Buy once, cry once?
What?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
There we go.
We're going to talk to gas.
Oops, I accidentally switched.
Am I supposed to crawl underneath here?
Huh?
Oh, jump over it.
Okay.
There we go.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Another one.
Ding, ding, ah.
Oh, fuck, this fucking button.
Get you a Sanrio Xbox controller.
Are there Sanrio Xbox controllers?
I would really like that.
Buy once, cry once.
Refers to buy it once expensive and make sure it's high quality or else you'll buy it again
because the first time it was just a cheap scam.
Oh.
I don't know about that.
Because for me, it's buy once, cry a lot because your rats chewed on it and now it's broken
and you have to buy it again.
That's how it is for me.
And don't talk to me about, oh, just hide it from your rats.
Oh, just put it in another room.
Shut up.
You don't know how it is.
They will literally escape my room.
They will escape my room while I'm literally walking out of it.
Yeah, nothing can be hidden from the rats.
Oh, by cord protectors, I do.
And they chew through the cord protectors.
Okay.
Yeah, there's no hiding anything from Esteban.
She'll find it all.
At least they're cute though.
Yeah, I forgive them because they're cute.
My guy's never seen pinky in the brain.
Uh-uh, I don't know what that is.
Uh-uh.
What?
Just got here, what are the rats chewing through everything that I own?
Microsoft, Amazon, and Apple are pretty chill about customer service.
It depends.
They'll probably ban me after a couple of times.
What are you going to do to a brain?
Nothing.
What?
It's about two lab rats.
One is a doofus and the other wants to conquer the world.
Oh, one is the brain and the other is insane.
Oh, I never watched that.
No.
Oh.
I should turn these.
Why won't it turn?
What?
Am I doing it wrong?
Why won't it turn?
Is it really that bad when owning rats or just exaggerating?
No, it's not bad.
They will chew on everything.
They will chew on your clothes.
Any time you hang out with them, they'll chew on you, on your clothes.
It's not bad though.
I have nothing.
I'm complaining, but I still love them a lot and it's, I'm not, I'm not mad about it.
I know how to sew, so it's okay.
What's, what am I doing wrong?
Oh, Q and E.
That's it, right?
Sorry about the dog downstairs.
That's supposed to be it, right?
And then, and then the other one too.
And then this one goes to, wait, where does this one go to?
Do the rats shed hair everywhere like dogs and cats do?
A little bit, just a little bit.
It's not a lot.
Rats are known to chew through phone lines for company offices, so yeah, it's no exaggeration.
My mom had rats in her backyard because her boyfriend wouldn't stop putting bird food out in the backyard and that would attract rats too.
And so they chewed on her, I think they chewed on her air conditioning wires and she had to get those replaced.
Like they chew on everything.
You should bark back.
No.
I don't have a dog, it's my neighbor's dog, I don't have a dog.
They were really cool rats though, they were really big.
It goes to the post you moved around.
Like that?
Oh, thank you, okay.
Did you take care of those rats?
No, no I did not, they were not, they were not my responsibility, I did not, I did not take care of them.
There's a theory that can kill the Rosariver.
I was crazy once, they locked me in a room, the sisters room, a sister room filled with Emmy, and Emmy makes me crazy.
Emmy makes you get crazy, she shouldn't make you crazy.
The roles are reversed from what the show makes you think, with the brain being the insane one, Pinky being the genius, playing dumb, huh?
I haven't watched it so I don't know.
I don't know anything about Pinky and the brain.
Is that all I have to do in here?
I need to get on top of the cage behind you to start the electricity.
On top.
Oh.
Let's go, thank you, did I do it?
Was that it?
Did I do it?
Did it work?
This is blue now.
It worked, it's blue now.
Okay.
And then, and then, and then what?
You need more power.
Good girl.
Thank you.
Um, okay.
Do I...
Do I do this?
Like that?
No, is that not it?
Moving the posts around.
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
Oops, what the fuck?
Okay.
Um, oh wait, is it?
Ah, that was close too.
Like that?
Wait, like this?
Yeah, I figured it out.
Okay, and then I open the door too.
No, it didn't open the door.
Come on!
Oh, it did open the door.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, we're getting progress done, and now this blue one.
Did I already go through here?
I did.
I'm so smart!
I'm so smart.
What am I even doing playing this game?
I should be playing like, brain games.
Are you smarter than a 5th grader?
I wanted to play Are You Smarter Than a 5th grader on stream, but the game has really bad reviews, so I was like, I probably shouldn't.
Does anything work now?
No.
Who was the big machine in Twistle ever?
You mean the button?
The lever?
Show us how you play factorial.
What's factorial?
Brain age would be fun on stream.
I had that game on the DS, and I would play it all the time.
I would always tell me, because I was like a little kid when I had that game, and it always told me that my brain was really old.
Where does this one go?
I'm hearing scary sounds and it's scaring me.
Wait, I'm getting scared. What does that sound?
Oh my god!
Oh no! Someone killed the path!
Okay, I sent you another key. It's under the statue. Use it to get into Home Sweet Home.
Then once you're inside, find the building's backup generator. Good luck!
Okay, key under the statue. Use it to something about Home Sweet Home.
How do I leave? How do I leave here?
Key under the statue, something about Home Sweet Home.
Your Uber's here?
Your Uber's here! Get in!
I didn't order an Uber!
Well, how's it go? I don't care!
That's the way? Okay.
Am I getting a loading screen?
What?
Are we gonna go through like a chase scene or something now?
Uh oh. Ah, this is scary!
All he sounds like Dora? I don't think he does. I don't think he does.
Wait, I already forgot what he said! What did he say?
Oh my god, I almost spilled my water.
Key under the statue, right? Key under the statue? Home Sweet Home.
Is this the statue he's talking about?
What statue?
In the center building. This one, this one, okay.
Oh, I don't like when it saves and makes me scared.
Who's pissing in here?
Uh...
Why am I hearing sounds?
Key under the statue?
Oh look!
Was this always this destroyed? Someone broke this!
It was the cat, wasn't it?
The cage you opened before.
Oh, another one.
Restore power in Home Sweet Home. Okay.
The monster's pissing?
I'm kinda scared.
It's pretty though, they have stars.
That was the sound of the key arriving, I hope so.
Okay.
I'm actually kinda scared of the dark.
I used to always sleep with a nightlight, cause I'm scared of the dark.
And now I have those frickin' TikTok LEDs in my room, so I don't need a nightlight anymore.
But every time I would go to sleepovers with my best friends...
Home Sweet Home. Home Sweet Home.
Every time I would go to sleepovers with my best friends, they didn't like the light,
and they would be like, turn off the light, I can't fucking sleep!
And so I would have to sleep with no nightlight, and I was always so scared being in the complete darkness.
Um...
At least there's lights here.
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna get... I'm gonna get lost.
Did I just go in a fucking circle?!
Home Sweet Home. Home Sweet Home. Home Sweet Home.
This is Home Sweet Home, right?
Or no, this is Home Sweet Home.
Which one's Home Sweet Home?
The front of the house is glowing red.
Is it that one?
Neither of them are Home Sweet Home!
This one looks like it's glowing.
Road closed.
Is this house... Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Is anyone home?
I'm looking through your windows!
That's the thing I kind of like to do.
I used to work really, not really late at night, but I used to work until closing a lot.
And so anytime I would walk home alone, I would like look through people's windows,
because no one would close their blinds at night.
And it was nice, because it was like, damn, your house looks so cozy.
I didn't do it in like a creepy way, like, ooh, I'm gonna break into your house.
I just kind of did it in like a... a curious way.
And sometimes it would be awkward, because then like people would be in their house,
and they would look outside, and they would see me...
I wouldn't like stare and like stand into their back yard and stare,
but like they would see me walking by and like looking at them, and that was awkward sometimes.
I also like to stare at people's porches, like they're friend of the houses,
and sometimes people are on their porches, and sometimes they stare back, and that's awkward too.
Oh, there's people here.
There's like real pictures of people here.
Is this the door?
Oh look, it's the pillow of the cat.
Not in a creepy way standing on the sidewalk outside of your house, watching your TV.
I wouldn't watch their TV.
Oh dude, something...
Am I gonna die?
Oh my god!
Ah! Oh my god!
Nothing happened.
Check the drapes you can see, the drapes are also puppy playtime approved.
Oh, that's cool.
That's such a cute detail.
How's your poison resistance?
Wait, am I gonna die if I stay here too long?
Run, run, run, run, run, run!
I mean, not even getting scared at the actual jump scares?
Wait, well there hasn't been an actual jump scare yet.
Am I supposed to go in one of these?
There's no puzzles here, just keep moving forward.
Okay.
Catnip box through.
Do you hear that?
Is this radio?
Wait, where did my, where did my hands go?
Happy, happy and fun way, way?
Happy and fun way, was it love?
What?
Happy and...
Fuck, I really need to pee.
Happy and fun way, was it love?
What does that mean?
No, cause you put the volume to like 30.
Don't go yet?
Shut up.
We're not doing that right now.
I'm gonna go this way.
What does that say?
Like, like, healthy?
Kick healthy?
I feel like this stuff has meaning.
I don't know.
I'm like the English teacher.
Are you kidding me?
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so dumb?
Huh?
It should blow up as soon as possible.
You're like shit.
Are you?
Shut up.
Let's watch.
Are you gay?
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Grab your popcorn? Okay wait, you're scaring me more than the game.
9.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
10.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
11.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
12.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
13.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
14.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
15.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
16.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
17.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
18.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
19.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
20.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
21.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
22.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
23.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
24.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
25.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
26.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
27.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
28.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
29.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
30.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
31.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
32.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
33.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
34.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
35.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
36.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
37.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
38.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
39.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
40.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
41.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy has been found on the estate.
41.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy had been found on the estate.
42.45 am, local authorities report that the body of a young boy had been found on the estate.
H labour short film
I'm back!
What were you talking about while I was gone?
Sorry, I kind of felt like I had to poo too, but I stopped myself.
Okay. Ready?
I'm ready. I'm ready.
Okay.
I want to go this way.
Actually, wait.
No, there's some scratch marks on both sides.
So, someone say we need an immediate email?
I...
I can't see anything.
Oh, they're accusing Elliot.
Right?
Let me make it...
Let me make it even louder.
Are you going to poop yourself?
No.
Everyone wants a pissy...
Twitch? I know Twitch reviews their...
Okay.
Okay, that was kind of scary.
I know Twitch reviews their emails that you send in.
Does YouTube do the same thing?
I don't like dark hallways, man!
Oh my god, stop!
They don't if you're a partner?
Well, I'm not a partner.
I don't know if YouTube reviews emails and if they're going to be like,
and this is so I don't...
Oh my god, I don't like that. Stop saying that.
That you the player character is Ludwig?
I'm Ludwig?
How'd they know it's piss for all they know it's lemonade?
There's another phone ringing.
What?
Why is it coming from?
I feel like I'm walking in a circle.
It's coming from the left?
Oh!
Oh, fuck you!
I heard footsteps!
I'm scared!
No, I heard footsteps!
Is he gonna chase me through the halls?
I'm scared!
I really don't like dark games.
I really, really don't like them.
Like, I put the brightness all the way up and I still can't see anything.
The game was at 100.
What does a cat do to prey?
Eats it?
What do you mean? Chases it?
Are you bad with horror?
I like playing them because they're fun, but I'm...
I'm trying.
How's the baby doing?
Why do you mean the baby?
What is it saying now?
He's talking about you.
The baby's doing badly.
Are there?
I hear purring.
Should I...?
I don't know what to do.
I'm getting scared.
Which way?
Which way do I run?
Wait, if I have to run, which way do I run until me right now?
Stop pausing.
Stop, you're scaring me.
But I feel like I should meet him first, right?
Stop.
I don't hear purring anymore.
You'll know if he chases you with me, don't worry.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying. I can't run now.
I haven't met him yet.
I can't see anything.
Is this an empty hole?
Or not a dead end?
Just keep going left?
Okay.
Which way is left?
This is what happens when kitten doesn't get kisses.
Didn't I come from this way?
Just keep heading forward.
I don't know which way is forward anymore.
I don't know which way is forward.
I'm kind of gay.
Why are you acting so gay?
Shut up.
Am I going the right direction?
Okay, wait. This is the dead end.
Stick to left?
Okay, I'll stick to left.
I know I'm going backwards. I'm confused.
I also can't see anything.
Guilt.
Guilt wants you.
Okay.
You're being too loud.
Open your eyes then.
How much handhold are we doing?
We're doing a lot.
Wait, this is another dead end.
This is another dead end.
There are no dead end.
This is a dead end.
We're doing a lot.
Are we doing a lot?
I don't know which way is forward.
We're doing a lot.
Are we doing a lot?
I don't know which way is forward.
Okay.
What is that?
But this is the sound.
It's coming from here.
Oh man, I'm just making myself lost, aren't I?
Go past radio.
Oh.
No, I feel like...
Huh?
Get up?
Me?
Get up.
He said go left, right?
Okay, left is a dead end here, so I'll go right.
Don't tell me what to do.
Only my big brother tells me what to do.
It's so hard to see.
I really can't see anything at all.
I think I'm looking into a wall.
This is another wall, isn't it?
Should I turn off my lights?
I seriously can't see anything.
Should it be like this?
Can you turn up the gamma?
No, it's already all the way up.
Was there something on the ceiling?
Okay, I'm going to turn my lights off to see if I can see more.
The hallway with the red light.
That did nothing!
Okay, hallway with the red light.
Is this one red?
I have not heard of Dark Deception though.
Happy and fun?
Why was it done?
There is no safety here.
Alright, that's comforting.
Because I don't like safety.
I don't make love.
I frick hard.
Where's the tape?
What it is?
Greetings, employees, and welcome to your first day here in playtime.
We're certain that in the days to come, you'll find your new family here every bit as loving and supportive as your own.
Feel free to wander the halls, sit in the mess for lunch, or watch our children play and learn to their little heart's content.
Join the innovationists, where the bounds of science are continuously purchased.
I feel like there should be another picture here.
I feel like I shouldn't just be huggy with them.
Sorry if you hear my chair creaking, it's very creaky.
Should you come back years later, your conscience finally getting the better of you.
May you descend into the dark and the dust, finding all that awaits you are incomprehensible horrors.
Wait, I can't look away from the TV, it doesn't let me.
Stop!
Back up?
I can't, I can't, I can't back up anymore.
You're scaring me.
The cat, oh I literally can't even move my mouse.
Stop scaring me.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Where's the door?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I can't run anymore than this.
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
I'm scared.
Was I walking?
I was trying to run, I was pressing shift.
Did I do it wrong?
Or was that supposed to happen?
Bro, that was supposed to happen, wasn't it?
Hold on, that was really loud when that happened.
It was supposed to happen, get ready to run, who cares?
Just let it kill me so I can get to the next part.
Get ready to run, Amy, it's happening, Amy.
Don't scare me like that, don't do that.
Just say it's okay, Amy, whatever happens next is supposed to happen.
Hello?
It's puzzle time again.
Can little sis use her gamer brain?
No.
I hear noises in these rooms.
Is more fun when you're scared?
I guess so.
Daddy, you long legs, hello.
I didn't, he doesn't talk though, that's okay, I like a quiet man.
I didn't know there was both a mommy and a daddy.
Oh, another hole, are we supposed to jump down?
Okay, I guess I'll jump down.
Sorry, I'm really picky about this audio.
I'll jump down now.
Get the gas mask?
Okay.
Where is it?
Am I dying? Am I dying? Am I dying? Where's the gas mask?
It was above you.
Well, now what?
Looking up is hard?
Oh.
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Why did you get so happy when you saw daddy long legs?
Is it a little emoto being a cheater?
No, I'm not.
I was happy when I saw mommy long legs too.
Pull the handle?
I would never cheat on you, don't worry.
What handle?
There's no handle in the car.
Back bumper?
Oh, go!
Okay, thank you.
Do I do it again?
Nothing happened.
Oh wait, looking up is hard.
Okay.
Oh, it's a washing machine place.
That's cool.
I do have a lot of dirty clothes.
Mommy long legs, daddy long legs, and there's a baby long legs.
How would a toy do that with each other?
It's a toy!
They just manufactured a baby long legs.
What the fuck kind of room is this?
Wait.
Wait, what?
Why are they staring into a kid's room?
Why are they looking into a little kid's room?
Huh?
They're observing the kids playing with the toys?
But there's a bed here!
This isn't an observation room, this is someone like,
this is a kid living here and sleeping in here.
What the fuck?
Can I not go through here?
Why do I still hear, oh wait, it's me.
How do I take it off?
There we go.
There's a man in the walls!
Was this like, did the cat break through here?
Close the door, close the door, close the door, close the door!
Did you see that?
You also look into people's homes, but that's different,
I don't look into little kids' rooms.
For toy popularity as well as testing the various medicines,
you can take mask off, yes I did it.
Didn't see it, oh my god, you're fucking blind.
He was right in this hall.
Which I can't go into.
Here's another little kid's room.
And another, oh no, oh my, these kids are so creative!
Everybody's so creative!
The cat stalks the halls, and guess who's the rat?
Me, I'm the rat!
Another door.
Oh, that's very nice of them, they make it easy.
And not the other one, I guess.
You're seeing things, you're gaslighting me!
Really, the rat makes her turn.
You're gaslighting me, Katnaps gaslighting me.
Everyone's gaslighting me, I don't deserve this.
Oh my god, she's breathing.
What do I do, she's breathing.
Oh no, she's looking at a picture.
Should I get closer, is that dangerous?
Take that picture, is she?
Get out of my room, I'm playing Minecraft!
It doesn't let me go.
I can't.
I thought she was dead at first, so I was like, what's going on here?
There's a furry on the wall!
There's like paintings of her.
Oh, it's the same girl.
That makes me sad.
Is this the place we came from?
Yeah.
Okay, I can't go through there.
She's waiting for me to go live?
I am live.
I'm live right now, you don't need to wait.
We're paying gloopy fatty time.
Where's the other pack?
Where's the other energy pack?
Stop being sad out here in your voice, I don't know why I felt bad for her.
Her being sad made me sad.
This game better have a good ending for Huggy and Kissy.
Up near Kissy?
Where was Kissy?
Where was she?
Hide.
Watch out.
Well, it's not in here.
Is it in this room?
Damn girl, you live like this?
I think this might be the last chapter that's out so far, but I think there's more chapters coming out.
90% sure it's not a spoiler because it's a theory based around the chapter 2.
A theory that Poppy will betray us at some point, like I said in chapter 2.
They replicated Amy's room. That's not true, shut up. It doesn't look that bad.
But the other battery pack isn't here.
Look up in the hallways, there's something to pull you up.
Oh, thank you.
I got random kids on the walls. I hope they got permission to get these random kids in their game because otherwise that would be awkward to steal pictures of random kids.
Why have you returned?
I don't know.
Why have I returned?
No, all the orphans.
All the orphans are dead.
Oh, someone, this one was also a robot.
Was it?
Returned for daddy long legs, obviously.
No, I came back for Huggy Wuggy if anything. Is that all I need in this room?
Because then I'm going to leave.
What happened here? Was a little kid bad or something and they locked him in his room?
Wait.
Oh, okay.
Sorry, I'm kind of scared right now. I know it's a puzzle, I shouldn't be scared, but...
Oh, the door opened.
Gamers can't look up, they discovered this during the play testing of Half-Life 2, so they put lights everywhere. This was eventually solved with bright yellow paint.
I just never think to look up, okay? How am I supposed to know? I look straight ahead, like a real alpha.
We don't look up at others, okay? We only look down at others.
Oh, it's you again.
Damn, that's so cool. Radical.
I would think one who's always so short would always look up. No, I only look down at people.
And then I tell them to open their mouth and I go...
Just like Sheevee.
None of these doors are open. Oh, this one's open.
I Hock-Twa. God, that meme is so cringe.
Am I supposed to watch something here?
I am gay. Why are you acting so gay?
Remember the name Dog Day? Nope, I don't. What about it?
Is there a dog here? Like, do they have a dog toy?
Very normie-pilled. I just think that meme is kind of cringe.
Like, it's like worse than Zoomer meme. It's like...
What's after Zoomer? What's the generation after Zoomer? I forgot.
Someone tell me. Generation Alpha?
Yeah, it's like Gen Alpha-pilled kind of meme.
Which is even worse than Zoomer memes.
There we go.
Now, what do I do with this?
And also, where's the tape for this?
Which one is it? Eat, eat, eat?
Can I touch everything until I find one that works?
I need to look up again.
Oh! Dammit.
Thank you.
Oh, there's another one.
What?
Wait, what?
Did I just get trapped in this room?
Are you kidding me?
That's what we say about Zoomer memes.
Zoomer memes are better than Gen Alpha memes. You gotta admit they are.
Gen Alpha memes is like stupid skibbity toilet.
You're so phantom tax, you're so fucking... I don't know.
You're so skibbity.
Are you gay? That's cringe.
Why are you acting so gay?
Ready to play a game? How about red light green light?
That doesn't tell me anything.
I thought skibbity was Zoomer. No, that's Gen Alpha.
No.
Zoomers did not give a shit about skibbity toilet. I can tell you that.
Oh! Oh, he's up now. He stood up.
Same thing with Ohio Sigma and all the other cringe ones.
The cringe ones that are bad and not based are Gen Alpha.
Okay, hot. Where's my fan?
Wait, where is my fan? Where did I put it?
Should I think I left it outside of my bedroom?
The Mock and Jalad. I have not even heard of the Mock and Jalad.
Where do I go?
I feel like I should go through here, but I can't.
It doesn't let me. And then I can't press this either.
Left of the door, there's an opening.
Here?
Which door? There's like three doors.
Left this door?
You were just there?
Is it this one?
But I couldn't go through that one.
This one?
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Oh!
You got the power. Okay, okay, okay, I got it.
But then where do I put it? Up here?
Oh, fuck.
Thank you for the $1 don't know. I don't know what you mean, though.
I don't know who's watching.
Okay, what did that do?
Did that just... What did that do?
I have a time limit for what? Does that open the door?
What did that do?
That was just to waste your time?
You're not being helpful. It's okay, I'll figure it out myself.
Maybe somewhere else?
We're trying here? Try harder!
There's a door that opens. Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry, I know you're trying your best. I'm sure some of you are trying hard to tell me what to do,
but it's getting lost in chat sometimes, too.
And also, I'm really bad at the game.
Okay, a door that opens.
I lose this power so quickly.
Spent this whole stream trying to cut her and she's yelling at me.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. I appreciate your help.
Thank you for helping.
Okay, now which door opened?
Oh, this one!
Okay, okay, I see it now. I see it now. Thank you.
I got it.
Wait, which door was it again?
Wait, I lost the door, I lost the door!
Oh, fuck, okay, okay, okay, I got this, I got this, I got this, I got this.
Here, fuck.
Here.
Oh, I lost the door again.
Okay, fuck.
It's that door.
I keep getting, like, confused.
Oh my god.
Whenever I keep going the wrong direction.
Get it! Touch it!
There.
Bro, I'm losing the door, I'm losing the door.
I'm losing the door every time.
I keep getting disoriented.
It's the door, it's the door, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, thank you, thank you, thank you.
It'll go right, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, thank you.
I keep, I'm really, really bad with directions.
I've always really been bad with directions.
Do I have to get this again from here?
No way, right?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, that was an easy door, that was an easy door.
Oh look, it's the bathroom.
Do you need to go to the bathroom?
You can go in through here.
Go left, go straight.
I don't, I don't actually know my left from right.
I just have to pull, like, take out my fingers and do that L.
Do that L shape with my fingers to tell which one's left and which one's right.
Um, hi.
Oh my god, he turned.
Oh, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Okay, nevermind, I thought I was going to turn away and he was going to be closer.
Um, you're just special, I am very special.
So, and you're special too.
We're special together.
He's hiding the battery from you.
Oh.
I used to think people not knowing they're left and right was a myth.
I no longer have that much faith in humanity.
Well, it's okay.
What am I going to do anyways?
You think I was going to find the cure to cancer?
There was never much faith in me to begin with.
So it's okay that I don't know my left from right.
Oh, that's too small.
I can't read that.
Hold on.
See you.
Emma's got to go.
Okay, bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
His mouth is wide open for me.
Ew, stinky.
And plus, you shouldn't open it.
You should just put your mouth on the source and suck it out.
Oh my god.
I surprised myself saying that.
Why are you acting so gay?
Don't worry, Emmy.
Anime's get closer when you look away.
That comes later.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, hey.
Got it from you.
Sucker.
Okay.
What?
What do you think the gen after gen alpha's humor will be?
And will it be worse than the skewery edge Riz, Ohio Rizzler sticker?
Yeah.
Humor.
I think it will be worse.
And I think, um, I think it's hopeless.
And I think we should all give up.
I don't really care that much.
I was never really one to be like, ah, fuck kids.
The fuck kids these days.
Yeah.
Like, oh, kids these days suck balls.
I hate them.
I've always just disliked kids, but it's not.
It's not really a kids these days kind of thing.
And it's also not kids that like kids.
It's not the kids fault that they have bad humor.
Their parents raise them to have shit humor.
So it's okay.
They can't.
It's not their fault.
Um, what do I do with this?
Stickin' out your gap for the Rizzler.
That's, I should shut up.
I should shut up.
Yeah.
Each generation is more current than the previous one.
And that's okay.
That's just, that's just a prophecy.
That's just how it goes.
Um, oh, okay.
There we go.
Nice.
Did we get, did we get a hundred percent battery?
Wait, where'd the other one go?
Who stole my other one?
Was it the cat?
Huh?
You were on the other side of the building.
Oh, what?
What do I do with this?
I am?
Huh?
Friends forever.
That's cute.
There's a thing over there, but it's not open.
But the rooms are so similar.
Oh, do I?
Hmm.
You have to find another battery.
You have to get like four batteries.
Oh!
That's so much work.
I can't expect me to do all that.
I like the music though.
Why are you acting so gay?
Oh, thank you.
I'm glad I'm not alone.
And thank you for the $5.
Why do you sound lost?
Because I am lost.
I'm perpetually lost in this game.
And perpetually confused.
And perpetually a little frustrated.
Both sexually and emotionally.
Wait, should I not say that word?
I noticed a lot of my vods get limited ads.
Should I say sexually?
No, that sounds too close.
Exually?
Exually lost?
Help.
Help me!
I'm the one that needs help.
Get to the door.
Yes.
Where is the power?
Where is it?
Oh, there's something here.
Okay.
Let me get...
Oh, it goes all the way up here.
Oh!
Is it closed?
Oh, shit, it closes after.
Oh!
Wait, oops.
Um, actually...
Um...
Did I just lock myself in?
I can't hit it through the bars.
Did I seriously just lock myself in here?
Did they not think about this?
Did they seriously not think about this?
That some stupid player like me would play and lock herself in the hall, in the stairs?
Vent?
What do you mean, vent?
There's no vent here.
I'm not the imposter.
I can't vent.
Oh.
That's fine, there's a vent here.
Which way do I go?
Does it matter?
Thank you for showing me the vent.
Wait, was I supposed to get stuck there?
Ah, they did think about the stupid players like me that would get stuck.
Okay, let's um...
I don't know, try this again?
Am I supposed to...
I don't know.
Man, I'm not smart enough for this.
This one definitely lasts a little longer.
You don't want to be there anymore?
What is this vent used for then?
Is it the same vent?
It is.
There's a door with two power sources that you need to open.
Yeah, I saw that.
Is it this one?
Okay, there's a door.
No, it's not this one.
It followed this, was it?
Where is that door?
No, you didn't?
It's right here.
Okay, it's right here.
So, do I just like...
I don't have the fricking directional skills for this.
I really don't.
So, here's the room.
I don't have the directional skills to find that door quick enough.
I don't know where the other room is.
Oh, that's the wrong door.
It's straight down the hall, it's easy.
No, it's not.
I promise you, I'm seriously not acting dumb right now.
I'm actually just dumb.
So, am I supposed to do this?
I feel like this isn't the right thing to do, is it?
Oh, but the other one just...
I don't think I'm doing it right.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
No!
You are doing it right?
You just need to be quicker?
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh my god!
Dude, I'm too stupid for this game!
I don't know if I can do it.
Power on the stairs is closer?
Bring up the guide?
There's another one?
But this power...
This power doesn't do anything.
Hold on.
No, that doesn't do it.
While the doors are open, grab the power from the upstairs hallway and use it for the second power.
I tried doing that.
Okay, I'll look up a playthrough.
I'll look up a playthrough.
Wait, am I on chapter three?
Wait, is chapter four already out?
No way it's out already, right?
Sorry, I'm getting a...
I'm getting a Popeye's bonus wings.
By the way, I tried those?
They sucked ass.
They were just chicken nuggets.
They sucked so hard.
Okay, we were past that.
Okay, we got there.
It's around 49 minutes?
Okay.
Okay, he puts it in there, and then what do you do?
Oh, he puts it in the other hole.
I guess it doesn't matter.
I hate it when they explore the game too.
I get so pissed.
I just expect them to know how to play the game right away and show me.
So I get so pissed when they're like,
Okay, what do I do here?
Oh, this room has nothing in it.
Okay, cool.
Okay, great.
Great.
Let's touch this random thing.
Also the time I look...
Okay.
Also the time I look up guides for games,
because I'm way too stupid and lazy to figure it out.
Well, I try to figure it out with your help.
Why is the screen like that?
I try to figure it out with your help,
but sometimes we're both too stupid.
And that's okay.
Okay.
Or sometimes I'm just too stupid to figure out your instructions,
which is probably the more accurate way of explaining it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Let's go!
Oh, you didn't even see that.
I forget YouTube covered it up.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize that I had the YouTube cover...
Oh, I had the YouTube covering it.
There's no monsters here.
Wait, there's nothing in here.
What was the point?
Oh, it's this?
Can we be sure that she actually did it on her own?
I cheated.
I hacked into the game.
I was covering up my tracks.
Why are all the toys hung by their freaking necks, bro?
And why does it keep telling me to hide?
There's nothing to hide yet, or nothing to hide from yet.
Okay, there's no toy hanging by its neck here, at least.
Chapter four.
I'd assume it's fan-made, but nothing says it is.
Tentacle tear with the character Octopussycat.
You made that up.
Tentacle tear.
Pussycat.
Chapter four.
Now the development of previous chapters.
Okay, so there's no official date, basically, is what it seems like.
Yeah.
There's no official release date.
Okay.
Octopussycat.
I may be stupid, but I'm not that stupid.
Ain't no way.
Uh-oh, gas mask, gas mask.
Did the gas kill all the kitties?
Oh.
Did all the kids die from gas?
Some toys didn't go along.
Understandable.
They made a different game so they might not care to finish this one?
No way.
This one's so popular, though.
I would really want to finish this.
Damn.
Staring at the kids.
Do I take this back now, I'm guessing?
The gas is used to subdue the kitties and make sure they stay compliant.
Is that real?
That's creepy.
I hope that's not real.
I mean, it did take a long time to get these games out.
I remember when it first came out.
It was quite a while ago, wasn't it?
Ah, I shouldn't have done that.
Okay.
So, it's okay.
I'm willing to wait for games.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Did the door open?
It's funny how that sounds like some little kids' logic,
but the game actually works like that.
What sounds like little kids' logic?
How long does it take me to get back to the battery room?
Uh, no time at all.
The gas was used to knock it-was-
I heard something fall.
Sorry, that scared the shit out of me.
Hold on, I'll be right back.
Thank you for watching.
I was still muted.
Okay.
Hi, everything's fine.
I heard something fall and I-I thought like a bookshelf broke down or something,
but apparently nothing fell, I don't know.
I didn't see anything wrong.
Um, I do think I'll stop here to, like,
yap a little bit and then end, though.
Um, just because it's getting really hot in here.
So, let me go back to the chatting screen.
Okay.
I'll talk a little more and then we'll-we'll, uh, continue the game another day.
I haven't already planned on my schedule for next week,
so we'll definitely keep playing.
Um...
Yeah, I'm-I'm cool and done.
I got-I found my fan.
I left it in the bathroom.
I also got chocolate.
You're getting to the good parts?
Well, we'll get to the good parts next week.
I literally have, um...
I have it done for next week.
I think it's the first game I play next week.
Though, I won't be able to stream on Tuesday.
Yeah, it's more bueno.
Sorry.
Um, I won't be able to stream on Monday,
because that's obviously my usual day that I don't stream,
and then I also won't be able to stream on Tuesday,
because I have-actually, do I choose-did I choose to stream on Tuesday?
Let me check my schedule!
I have a vet appointment, and it's in, like, the middle of the day on Tuesday.
I don't remember my password for the company schedule.
Um...
Alright.
I don't remember my password.
I'll check later.
So, I may do some more part two?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I don't know what I would do as a part two.
The problem with part twos is that, um,
every single, um, video I upload that has, like, a plot to it,
people ask for part twos.
So, like, yeah.
Like, every single video I upload with a plot to it,
I get, like, tons of comments asking for part twos,
so it's, like, I should really-I really just choose which, um,
videos I want to have part twos and which ones don't, and most don't.
Mostly because I don't know what else to say, you know?
Keep us up to date on the rat health.
I absolutely will.
Though, I don't know.
I feel like-I don't want to, like, stress you guys out with, like, rat health stuff,
because, um, like, I didn't-I didn't get my rats from, like,
I should put on the music, hold on.
I don't want to stress you guys out with, like, rat health updates,
because I didn't get my rats from any sort of reputable breeder or anything,
so their genetics are probably really fucked up,
so the chances of them, like, um, like, getting health issues is really high,
and I don't want to constantly be telling you, like,
oh, you know, another rat has another health issue, you know?
Because that's going to be really depressing, you know?
It doesn't stress me out, I just think they're cute.
We care about them, too.
It's just going to be so sad to tell you, like, every time a rat dies.
I don't know.
We care because there are rats, too.
There are family we want to know.
Okay.
Don't feel like you can't talk about it either.
Yeah, they're really short-lived, and, um,
and sometimes they die in really depressing ways,
so I don't want to, like, yeah, be updating you.
The depressing way my rat is dying.
Are you gay?
Sorry, I'm getting distracted.
I'm reading her.
Oh, why?
Wait, is there another one out?
Tuesday?
I don't know.
Is there already another one out?
Should we listen to it together?
Another audio watch along?
Oh, wait, I searched up Pinterest instead of Patreon.
That would be crazy.
There's no new one yet, unfortunately.
Should be tonight?
Okay, okay, okay.
Then we won't bully audio.
I don't even remember recording that one.
It should drop at seven, right, really?
Sometimes they are a little late.
Sometimes the editors don't have enough time to finish them,
um, right on the time they're supposed to, I guess.
I only just recently told Strani that if the editors are backed up,
I can edit my own audio.
So hopefully, if that ever happens in the future,
I can just edit it myself and have it up on time.
Sorry, I'm reading our Discord server right now.
I'm like, ooh, what is everyone talking about?
Every time I wake up in the morning, it's like the first thing I read.
I read what the other girls have been talking to each other about.
It's kind of fun.
It's a fun thing.
Like, I've never had, like, a group chat like this,
um, where, like, everyone talks to each other so often.
It's fun.
Um, you do watch alongs for those?
Not really, not officially.
Um, just, it's just for fun.
Last time I did it.
Oh, my chest.
Okay, um.
Yes, Poppy Playtime, our favorite Patreon reaction audio stream.
It would be nice to see your own touches on it.
Oh, well, I haven't written any scripts yet,
so it's not really my own touches.
It's mostly just my own editing and my own, um, sound effects, I guess.
Do you think you'll continue the last airbender watch along,
or did it not really grab your interest?
I don't know.
I, I feel like, I don't know.
I'm, I guess I'm just, I didn't, I don't, I just have this feeling
that, like, other people don't care about watch alongs.
I was like, I don't know if people want to see you.
I do the same with the community server.
That's cute.
That's nice that you guys have your own community.
I'm happy about that.
Don't, no, don't like discord.
No, no, no, no.
There is, there's not a T between us.
Of course, like, I'm not going to be like,
I fucking hate this other member.
Like, we're actually very, very, um, friendly with each other,
which is, like, apparently not always the norm between companies
and, like, their members.
Obviously, I won't be like, X person hates Y person in, in Z company,
but it's just like, um, like, I didn't know that, like,
like, it's, it's not every company is so chill.
I didn't know.
I hate scrawny.
No.
We do care.
I was down for watch alongs.
Aw.
Being work colleagues doesn't automatically make you friends.
Yeah.
That's true.
And I'm glad we are friends.
I'm glad everyone in, um, dealer is friends because it didn't,
you know, it didn't guarantee us to, to be friends,
but I'm glad that we all get along really well.
And I feel comfortable talking to all of the girls.
Like, I think every time we've had a collab together,
um, we've, we've, a lot of times, um, we were just staying in the call afterwards
and just talk after the collab for like a long time.
I'm glad because I know you and scrawny both really wanted some Vtuber pals.
Yeah.
I did.
And I, I was always pretty like shy to reach out to people.
I reached out to someone today.
I was really, really scared.
I reached out to someone today on Twitter and,
and they actually responded to me.
And I was so surprised that they did.
I was like, wow, they're talking to me.
That's so surprising.
I'm getting braver.
I'm getting braver because I was, I wanted, I was going to wait.
I was like, oh, maybe, maybe they'll reach out to me.
Right.
Then I was like, nah, nah, I should do it.
I should do it.
Don't wait.
Just do it.
And I did it.
And they responded.
Isn't that so exciting?
It was so exciting to me.
I, I was really, I was like, oh, my heart was pumping.
I'm proud of you for getting past the nurse.
I'm happy it's going well.
I'm happy too.
I was really scared.
I was super, super scared, but it went really well.
Only one I ever knew that was a clap.
Only one I ever knew that was a black company and a budget stuff coming out of
both behind the scenes bullying.
Do you mean Nishi Sanji?
Do you mean that one?
Should I not talk bad about Nishi Sanji?
I don't know.
Are we going to get blacklisted from, from collabing with Nishi Sanji?
That's okay.
Yeah.
I think, I think we all kind of know that.
I got a necklace.
Okay.
Bye.
Have fun.
Nishi stuff is pretty open.
Yeah.
Everyone knows about that.
That's already out.
That's already been out.
Don't be afraid to reach out in me.
Anyone who takes 10 seconds to watch your content knows how fun you are.
Yeah, but not everyone, you know, has time to watch my content,
so they might not want to, um,
see how based in real I am.
So,
yeah,
but that's okay.
That's okay.
That's, that's fine too.
Not everyone has to,
I don't, I don't expect everyone to, to reply to me.
But I'm happy when they do.
Like I talked to Lulu yesterday.
Like I said before, I was so surprised.
Lulu sounds so cute.
Lulu is so cute sounding.
When I heard her, I was like, holy crap.
Lulu, how old are you?
I was like, one of the first questions I asked her, I was like,
are you, are you a kid?
But no, she's, she's not.
She's not.
Um,
just want, just didn't want to say the name because it was like forbidden by YouTube.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, I'm glad the others are, are in a better place now too,
in, in the show, Jill.
What's the worst that can happen if you reach out though?
They say no thanks and that's it.
Um, the worst that can happen is they block me.
And I don't want to get blocked.
I just need to watch your tooting short.
Uh-uh, uh-uh.
Don't, if you're going to watch a short, don't watch that one.
Watch a better one.
I don't know which one to watch.
Maybe like the rat one.
The rat one is really good.
That one's a good one to watch.
Don't watch the one where I pooped.
Surely, surely no one is that insanely block you for reaching out.
I don't know.
Maybe they are.
I think about the worst possible outcome, you know?
that's the worst possible outcome or they like screenshot the dm and they
post it and they're like look who dm'd me look who tried to DM me how how
desperate I don't know like I think of the worst possible situation and I um I
get scared and this it scares me and it stops me from reaching out if they do
they have issues I know and if they do that I probably didn't wanna you know I
probably wouldn't want to interact with them in the first place I know would you
even want to collab with someone who'd be so petty they'd block you for reaching
out no you're right you're right yeah stick big bro on them then no I'm not
gonna send a hate mob I'm not gonna send a hate mob on someone luckily that
hasn't happened yet I'm quite surprised it hasn't I'm quite surprised but it
never it has not happened yet maybe one day if it happens I'll tell you me and
we both suffer from instant do more thoughts you'd be ready no no we don't
encourage hate here no we crave unity unity don't don't hate on don't hate on
random random long Twitter it's okay
mm-hmm oh Denpa is streaming maybe we can read then puth wait then puth is not
streaming what wait does then puth have is this a membership stream I know oh
it's a premiere oh 3DO ASMR cuddling in bed together oh I want to cuddle with
Denpa bro did you guys know that Denpa is also Canadian I hope she said that
before y'all ready for the Denpa Mercy in me collab you me off collab yeah she's
also Canadian okay I'm not gonna wash the premiere sorry Denpa all VTubers
are Canadian no they're not no you're surprised so many VTubers are can be
there's people that live here where she is Canadian wait did she not say that
oops sorry I thought she did I thought she did oops only Kyoko is live
she said that okay good she said it before sorry I'm so sorry I would feel
so bad if she didn't say if you if she didn't say that before and I said it oh
I would feel so bad oh I'm sorry Mercy I hope you said that you're Canadian
before she has said it okay good I would kill myself if I accidentally said
and she didn't want me to say it I feel so bad
Amy Docs is Mercy no I don't want to be a leaker I don't want to be a leaker I
didn't leak anything the only thing I leak is piss and score okay I'm gonna set
up the redirect for me redirect okay the first wheeler drama Mercy hates Amy
for leaking her address okay um I'll see you the Thursday yeah Thursday and
as soon as I mentioned P everyone's like can I have some may I ah I'm ready Amy okay I'll
see you again on Thursday yeah we're gonna be rigging or if I'm like really
really if I'm really really productive which I'm really usually not but if I'm
really productive we might we might be doing something more exciting than
rigging we'll see we'll see I don't want to spoil it I won't spoil it we'll see
we'll see yeah thank you for coming thank you for helping me thank you for
guiding me through poppy playtime I'm sorry if I got frustrated it gets
frustrating sometimes for me um yeah I'll see you Thursday bye bye love you
pookie
you